[Music]
if anything for a selfie news first let
me take a selfie the minute by
billionaire David's I thought like I
know I got really happy like if I was a
billionaire you think I'd be here right
now I probably would be yeah I don't
think my life would change my I tell you
what happened father
are you kidding me you would have the
craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] right now you
would probably be levitating in a
[ __ ] alien costume that's not that
much changing you wouldn't even know if
all the building here that save you
[ __ ] Jay King is with me right now
being sane how huh oh we could reenact
all our [ __ ] scenarios I'll be in a
kitchen
give me a billion dollars you can just
buy your own plane to jump out of an
aquarium is charging visitors a hundred
and forty five Dallas for the chance to
scoop polar bear poop what like it's a
pool is a polar bear this is this a
lottery system like it's like a raffle
ticket you might have the chance to
scoop food what is not eyes a polar bear
poop by the land are you gonna ever pick
up all the bear poop I'd pay it that's
the size of a baby why would I want to
pay to pick up [ __ ] I lost your [ __ ]
right it's experience
I don't give a bull better they say I
want to experience you want it you would
do it in a heartbeat
ah do I get to see the polar bear at
least no but every day okay so first of
all this takes place in China
well I'm not going to China I retract it
right at you you don't want to go to
China Humera crap no I marry Taiwan same
[ __ ] you vary Taiwan but I can't you
know back up ever no you got back up you
got emotional back up that happens after
the cameras off yeah so if this is a
phase three say three hours service
available at wicket wha
long high time Ocean Park okay thank you
think of it and it is only done once a
week so that's why it's like if you get
pictures you have to submit they only
clean the pen once a week no they open
this up for turrets okay why they're
still smart they're making money and
having people do that work for them who
want to clean the windows once a week
you get to clean all the windows a month
long
yeah well they say that participants get
to clean the den prepare food and see
the Bears
oh so it's a whole experience you get to
be a zookeeper oh yeah you get a quick
health check and you also get to learn
about we hug a legit job we get we get
them and then you didn't get a real job
interview you know I call your reference
but you have to pay no I don't really do
well yeah I guess maybe I mean I don't
know if humans can transfer disease
members maybe something along the lines
of you know that is kind I'm not the
polar bear was going to give them the
health check or something to do yeah so
they're saying but they also get to
learn about the polar bears be full of
edge to polar bear the boo-boos I would
pay to feed a polar bear I don't know if
I want to feed it
would you want to pet one I would want
to pet one I would but then I'm so
scared
hey remember a myth well there's wasn't
a make a little bit oh we are what the
[ __ ] are you doing
the woman the crews would enter Gaza in
Taniya
whenever the [ __ ] little composition
refused to look I [ __ ] was expensive
they must be out their [ __ ] mind
that's pure exploitation I don't want to
it was like 70 dollars just to have a
tested pair of tiger oh so sad so you
wouldn't see you've died in the same
light I'd be pen I guess I have to see
the living conditions out to see if it's
a sanctuary or if it's just like the zoo
it seems like it's like an aquarium it
is a little bit different in Ensenada
that was a restaurant of course they're
not prepared to support wildlife if it's
a zoo I think I feel a little bit better
about it connect system living yeah and
they're feeding them and cleaning up
after them yeah there
like making them like take pictures or
anything formal they are though so for
this of course this experience they do
offer the opportunity to take selfies
with the Bears
that's how can be dollars one hundred
and forty five dollars seven day was the
one from Ensenada to papaya
I will say though even though it looks
very cruel and there was bad articles
about it
I saw the tiger come playing with the
guy and he was like he loved them yeah
and they were like wrestling with each
other for a good like ten minutes I
never looked yeah I asked that employee
dude
and I only asked him this just to see
what his response would be in the
reaction but I told him like hey I heard
that you guys drugged up the animal he's
like of course not why would you do that
to our animal but he got so defensive so
I'm like oh [ __ ] oh maybe here's a is it
true that you give them a little right
and he was like what the [ __ ] do that we
did not like that but yes he did get he
got really defensive
we got flustered huh something like that
we're always like you could do dragon in
they don't know that we play mafia so he
wasn't ready what we're here my bad over
there you know he never plays it there
that's because you guys do crazy [ __ ] if
you want David to play on take a party
planner comments below how about you
shut the [ __ ] up David so on JK party
yeah yeah let's do that happened but if
this video gets to a million views I'll
go to JQ sorry okay no I don't need a
million views just bombard him yeah salt
we know your views Bart is Instagram
page is faces yeah take the attention
away from McDonald's put that attention
on the no no no don't don't don't
that's not a big enough sacrifice you
better do I thought you liked hanging
out with us I do like hanging out do you
guys but I don't like something on
people's toes I don't like spit balls in
your mouth
I don't like peeing on TV you think I
like that [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] half
these our activity for us to bond
together they don't like it got them but
I have to do it stupid when we give you
less punishment you like what the
yeah you up in yourself yeah but I don't
go that's it Oh give your dick to that
yeah it's different okay
different finally this video get to a
million views I will go to take a party
don't worry about the views hashtag
David's we know you've been hash tag me
as much as you want you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright a little work that's why he
doesn't want any wants this video I had
a million if you can get the video to a
million I have a couple my like if you
get this video to a million views I will
other one JK party you [ __ ] that is the
worst thing you could do to me yeah you
knew you people anyways back on the
Polaroid post here's a photo that they
provide with all that polar bears about
white anymore no more album bear my head
isn't brown bear so this photo has been
used to report the story so I don't know
if this is part of the experience or if
it's just like a stock photo look at the
size of that Duke it's like a pack of
hot dog that's a lot of Dookie there's
like Tyson poop god damn no I think it's
way big it covers the whole shovel eight
times actually I should look at mounts
like this big some animals [ __ ] like so
much it's like a JanSport backpack size
- poor little other friends I think
that's all we all know he done support
that was the cool people at was if you
had the East pack backpack Google little
name yeah too bad [ __ ] pack so got a
little pop in because then it means
combined with them and now that's a
[ __ ] $500 backpack Wow for real no
it's a JanSport the weak one huh I like
a giant support I've always liked these
packs and em because you weren't cool
you also have an Android Junior I didn't
want to be cool okay hahaha that's
America don't hang on androids we could
do a lot more things on our phone that's
what they all say we could customize ooh
yeah that's the amazing part about it
and then the apps work better on
androids I can't you know what though I
do like it David David is so close to
getting one David's the most wishy-washy
person we all know Julia you can't be
what am i wishy-washy always how odd you
say to give me an example please here's
your first you she was about to say
something you cut her off
that's why and i anyways I'm going to
ask you guys those no I want to know
what I asked you guys though if you can
have like an intimate experience with an
animal knowing that you'd be so I'm good
I'm not tough [ __ ] animal knowing
that you'll be safe and knowing that
this animal is not being harmed
no way oh can we pick one no [ __ ]
animals
okay we got your answer you get a lion
chimpanzee I don't know it's really hard
to choose I want to talk to you about
that yeah that's it that's it was like
horrible a wolf I already did that yeah
yeah a lady lion or a man lion a lioness
oh the nose no main one huh you want to
touch the main I want a lion yeah cuz I
want to feel like their skin I want to
look into their eyes on just [ __ ]
grab the food like it's a [ __ ] cute
and then watch it you know she said I
can't get harm I think your commute yeah
a cheetah or like a Jaguar any doesn't
eat you could ride my Jaguars is outside
ha ha ha I think for me I want to want
to interact with the whale like in
person a beluga whale or a sperm whale
if you've ever been will watching I have
but like I learn to swim with a [ __ ]
win win you can do that though yeah
they're just gonna be the size of his
eyeball I know I want to see how massive
that it is like in front of me and that
was she saying you could just go to it
go to downtown Kingman and then look at
a building with the walls right here
that's what it's like to interact with
the look where you just entertainer
softly I have internal helper you
couldn't do that you could swim a whale
yeah we're I'm sandwich shocks my cousin
did that but like you can't touch a girl
you legally like you can't touch that as
I in this fantasy world of crocodile you
would want any thank you guys
if I can't remember that bet dude
remember that not
out the gutter calm down that's the cup
the [ __ ] that's what the
crocodile passed away but he was
actually befriended a [ __ ] oh yeah
cool that's okay Isaac how the baby
crocodile you did when we went to floor
baby holding a baby yeah baby it was a
bit hello matter people do you want to
contact me and everybody else you see go
ahead and check the description box
below and follow our social medias
instagrams and Twitter's for more videos
click up there baby
[Music]